ce n'est pas tous les matins que les
enfants du premier ministre vont à
l'école avec leurs pairs et des
cameramans les milliers d'hommes et de
femmes de tous les partis ne verront pas
beaucoup leurs familles au cours des
quarante prochains jours
les canadiens se rendront au jour aux
urnes le 21 octobre prochain
le chef libéral a tout de suite donné le
ton de sa campagne no vision pour le
pays sont très différents entre l'
approche libérale qui est positive et
inclusive et l' approche conservatrice
qui veut prôner les coupures et
l'austérité
cette vision inclusive se heurte à la
nouvelle loi québécoise sur la laïcité
qui interdit le port de signes religieux
dans la fonction publique et les écoles
je ne trouve pas que dans une société
libre on doit légitimiser ou permettre
la discrimination contre quiconque mais
juste être doux dit ne pas avoir
l'intention de contester la loi
pour l'instant le premier ministre du
québec lance un appel aux chefs fédéraux
ce que je leur demande c'est de
s'engager pas juste pour l'instant pour
de bon à ne jamais contester la loi qui
interdise signes religieux pour les
personnes qui sont en autorité le compte
à rebours pour que le canada se
débarrasse du gouvernement d chaque tige
et trudeau est officiellement lancée
leader conservateur a taclé tegris du
chef libéral
l'ami deux fois par le commissaire à
l'éthique dans l'affairé cen c'est
notamment le global mail en rajoute ce
matin en dévoilant que le gouvernement
trudeau bloquerait lankais de la grc sur
cette affaire elle doit mettre fin
immédiatement à ses tentatives de
bloquer l enquête policière dans
plusieurs circonscriptions au québec
comme ici à trois-rivières les
conservateurs pourraient l'emporter si
le bloc québécois ne performe pas c'est
ne pas le bloc qui va remplacer justin
trudeau
c'est pas le bloc qui va laisser plus
d'argent dans vos poches
la dernière semaine
bizarrement nous sommes devenus le
principal des conservateurs le chef du
bloc québécois a lancé sa campagne dans
la région québec où il pourrait
reprendre certains comtés demandons nous
si justement il ne faut pas relancer
avec vigueur cette idée de faire du
québec un pays
le chef bloquiste a que juste être dos
de nuire aux intérêts du québec jacques
médecine lui accuse les libéraux de
vendre laurent mon l'aube et des
pétrolières et des grandes entreprises
il promet d'annuler le contrat des armes
vendues à l'arabie saoudite entre la
priorité de la population et les grands
compagnie les conservateurs et les
libéraux toujours choisi les priorités
de l'écran compagnie pour la chef du
parti vert c'est l'élection la plus
importante de l'histoire du pays en
raison de l'urgence climatique
on ne veut pas faire peur dit elle mais
donner de l'espoir
nous allons créer des millions d'emplois
dit elle en convertissant le pays aux
énergies renouvelables d'ici 2030
maxime bernier promet lui de réduire
l'immigration de 60 % 49 % des gens qui
veulent moins d'émigrer au canada
seulement 16% qui en veulent plus tous
les chefs sauf le bloquiste seront dans
la région de toronto en début de
campagne où le vote des nouveaux
arrivants pourrait être décisif ici
sophie langlois radio canada montréal